okaygo the design of the dress is the
same as it has some that hasn't changed
at all the only thing that's been
changing is the image is sort of in flux
again depending on how things work and
that kind of thing which we're testing
right now we've been testing the lights
we're trying to figure out exactly what
we want them to do in response to the
heart rate we are using a heart rate
sensor rather with a microphone that
will be housed on the back of the brooch
which will be on the inside of the top
the bodice as someone who does costume
production it is a very collaborative
process all the time so I'm always
working with a designer and other makers
you know we divide things up into
specialties so that you can accomplish
something in the best way possible so
this is a very familiar scenario to me
but it's also even more exciting because
it's such different specialties working
together to create something new this is
the computer-generated image of the
graph that we're working with that will
be put on to the actual dress and we
print it out so that we can actually lay
it down on the real-life patterns for
the skirt and then kind of like measure
what the distance is between things
david is sort of like our software
engineer graphic designer in working on
this image so we can go back and forth
with him for example I'll like show him
on the floor this is what my pattern
looks like and this is what that picture
looks like printed on it and I want to
tilt it like this and we have to divide
it here and usually okay let's figure
out how to do that and we measure and
kind of put it in so these are the
clusters is one of the colleges the size
of the cluster is sort of the population
of the college and then the line
connecting two clusters represent how
many credit hours students in these
colleges take in the other college and
so the sort of the thickness of this
group of lines here means more credit
up alright David we have to do some
changes it's too fragile and here see
how it like already it's too thin
especially because this is even stiffer
fabric than what we'll be using I think
this was really beautiful if you could
keep it straight to do that because then
even here I can poke through you know
okay what we didn't expect was that all
these lines are so close together that
when the laser cutter cuts them out
there's so little fabric left in between
but it just tears and so we're trying to
figure out the best way to deal with
that so for example I could grab these
and just make them all much thinner so
there's less fabric missing so the whole
thing is sort of structurally more sound
or we could go through and just have you
know half as many lines which you know
also results in less fabric getting cut
out we're just trying to decide what's
going to look the best so right now the
thickest point in the center of the line
is ten units across so if I make it like
a three
we could go thinner once we can get the
skirt cut out I can actually start like
putting the skirt together there will be
things we have to kind of figure out as
we keep experimenting with that and then
as we start to house it into the garment
how everything hooks up how it is in
there so that it's an easy way to deal
with it switches and those kinds of
things and all that so yeah